[Music]
i tell you something on innovation the
bolder we can be the better
the more we can break the rules the
better off we're going to be because you
know the world is full of ideas today
and if we don't do it somebody else is
going to do it in fact i'd say little
startups are capturing a lot of the
growth today even in our space even in
the food and beverage space so in many
ways in our company we have to act as if
we're a bunch of little startups that's
what we are a bunch of little startups
so in order to do that we've got to
allow people
to be
bold you know write the rules any way
they want and that's what they do
as millennials have come into the
workforce in large numbers their
expectations of companies have changed
they no longer look at it as sort of a
paycheck but they look at it as how can
i go to work and make a difference in
society so the notion of purpose is
becoming a much bigger factor the big
difference is that in the past purpose
used to be
some sort of a corporate social
responsibility program and typically
those programs were good people liked
them
but they were at the whim or fancy of
the ceo who was there so if the ceo
retired that program got cut
so we had to weave purpose into the core
business model of the company how do you
make sure that the sense of purpose
can only be accomplished if you make
profits
and the only way to make profits is
through purpose and that's why we you
know use the term performance with
purpose linking both together and i
think that's what's
excited millennials in particular and
what's excited the boomers to even stay
longer in the workforce because they
actually feel they're contributing to
the future of society as opposed to
walking in picking a paycheck and
leaving so the whole equation with
employees is changing
first
please be a lifelong student
you know when we are kids we ask
questions like why is the sky blue why
is the bird flying so high but for some
reason as we get older that curiosity
goes away
and if we are happy with the knowledge
we have then we are actually going to
atrophy
so please remain a lifelong student
don't lose that curiosity and the most
important one
please help others rise
greatness comes not from a position but
from helping build the future
all of us in positions of power have an
obligation to pull others up
you know as i stand here today
i look at my responsibility not as
accepting and honor i look upon it as
accepting a challenge and a
responsibility an obligation to actually
make it possible for the people who are
younger to come up and achieve levels of
greatness so they too can be on the
stage sometime in the future
so thank you again ngtv for this
incredible honor thank you ladies and
gentlemen if you only had successes you
know what do we have to learn from
i can't tell you how many failures
one has had business wise personally
you know
over my career my 40 year career
sometimes i look back and say did i just
have bad luck or what happened i look at
each of them each of those failures as a
teaching or a learning experience
because
i went back and i thought about what did
i do wrong that i failed
or what was wrong with my behavior that
ticked off somebody else and when you
look at each of these as teachable
moments
you become better and more humble after
failure
so it's how you approach the failure
rather than the failure itself
that makes you better families are very
very important very important they give
you foundation
and
when everything fails you've got family
so we should never underestimate the
importance of family whatever family
means you know in those days it was a
definition of a family today the
definition of a family may be different
but we have to recreate that belonging
and a sense of support in some shape or
form in our communities second families
are messy i don't know of a single
family that doesn't have
some complications so families are messy
families are fragile
you don't know when your family is going
to be
even perturbed by something corporate
upset a lot of families in my case it
was my father's accident
fortunately he
recovered and went back to work but had
he not our whole history will have
changed so families are fragile and in a
family the men and women have to be
educated and they have to have both the
power of the purse
if that doesn't happen families
disintegrate
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here